un vrai gentleman sait comment
nouer correctement une cravate pour chaque occasion, vous constaterez
qu'une lavallière ou un nœud papillon est parfait
pour étouffer un agresseur si la
situation nécessite un nœud plus formel
car il faut des menottes.
les boucles pincent et tirent de
chaque côté appliquent une traction et tada
vous
au
dîner n'oubliez jamais de déplier votre serviette
et de la placer sur vos genoux c'est un
excellent moyen de déguiser des armes jusqu'à
quatre couteaux à des armes à feu de différentes tailles
ou un plus petit arsenal d'équipement peut être
discrètement caché tout en conservant
un air de sophistication
un gentleman utilise toujours la fourchette appropriée
vous en aurez besoin d'une autre en fonction
des dommages que vous avez l'intention d'infliger
rappelez-vous le travail de l'extérieur pour les
mutilations légères commencez par la fourchette à huîtres pour
quelque chose de plus mortel essayez un
fourchette à dîner robuste ou pour une portée supplémentaire la
fourchette à fondue cela vaut la peine de s'accrocher aux
choses les plus fines de la vie
prenez ce plateau en argent antique c'est une
pièce classique  e qui fait le parfait
bouclier impromptu les balles tirées de
loin peuvent être arrêtées et à la rigueur, il
peut également dévier un lancer de couteau si la
force brute doit être appliquée le plateau est un
objet contondant fiable que
vous